referencing beloved material hoping it
will add gravitas to your comedy
otherwise known as hitching your wagon
okay now you're just trolling right
why is the in show titled the simpsons
halloween special three but the
reference title is treehouse of horror
three seriously this is your third year
doing this make up your mind already
episode not created by matt groening
behold mighty caesar
in all his glory
person doesn't realize their clothes
fell off until after everyone else does
even though it should be patently
obvious for a variety of reasons cliche
stupid party wish we was
trick-or-treating
now bart you can find just as much
horror around the house
i believe bart is talking about candy
and not horror so i'm honestly not sure
what marge is talking about they could
have come up with a better segue than
this to get the stories is all i'm
saying
also do the simpsons appear to be the
family on the block that would be
throwing the halloween party
this would be like the bundys being the
place everybody goes to to get into the
christmas spirit
and these are her brains
why would you give a kid a raw steak do
you want to be known as the trichonosis
house because this is how you get known
as the trichonosis house
this lowercase i is driving me crazy
it'd be one thing if they went full meme
culture and randomly capitalized letters
willy-nilly but this is literally the
only letter that isn't capitalized
why what is this foul dominion of
torture and why does it affects me so
when did this change from a family
birthday party into a birthday party
with friends
great caesar's ghost a talking krusty
doll
i have no clue how old bart is supposed
to be and after 31 seasons i'm pretty
sure no one does but i'm guessing he's
well past caring about a talking doll
years old
i mean killer dolls suck and stuff but
this one is kind of on you for leaving a
butcher knife behind the couch
funny joke and all but should you really
have included it mere moments after
homer said
didn't even pull the string that time
stay consistent with your string theory
simpsons
attempting to wash yourself in your own
filthy human stew
what exactly is homer running past here
i feel like the animators asked what
matt groening wanted and he just said
paint diarrhea
i was a fool to think anyone would want
nude photos of whoopi goldberg
what the can i both defend whoopi
goldberg from this unfunny attack on her
appearance
and at the same time acknowledge the
irony of this happening 28 years before
she publicly shamed bella thorne for
having her nude pictures hacked
no no room for nuance in 2020 okay fine
just ding it and you decide what the sin
is for
also this is right in the midst of
goldberg's work on star trek the next
generation
you're telling me there wasn't some
gaining fanfics that needed some
pictures to go along with it
cape crusty also of course krusty
getting out of the tied up bag the
chained up suitcase and the bottomless
pit is sinful
but if he was able to get out of all of
that and catch up to homer's car why did
he bother buckling himself up underneath
it if you're gonna do four impossible
things you might as well do five or six
and you'd be a hero to the mad hatter
and alice in wonderland
ew dog water who has their dog's water
bowl in the middle of the kitchen floor
like this
really curious how you dial an
apostrophe also curious why there's a
hotline set up to specifically keep sue
from doing stuff
nice little mysteries i guess yep here's
your problem
someone said this thing to evil why
wouldn't the hotline just tell you that
over the phone
also this is lisa telling this story to
a bunch of people at a halloween party
why the heck would you tell a scary
story about a doll from hell that ends
with the doll having a simple switch
that turns him from evil to good
you've led an interesting life that's a
lie and you know it
but i have seen a lot of movies
conversations i will have with my future
grandkids somehow make their way into
this episode
wearing a jacket without putting your
arms through the sleeves what do you
think smithies
i think women and semen don't mix
that joke is so subversively funny i
can't believe it actually aired on
primetime network tv
i'm here about duran it doesn't have an
address but i figured dang that
opportunity must be somewhere near the
dock so i came as soon as i could
ah so a single gas bomb takes down this
giant creature in seconds but when burns
accidentally sets one off at his own
feet it only makes him prance around
singing pretty sure the show has that
gas backwards
the way this section hilariously
satirizes kong and still manages to pay
homage to and faithfully honor it is
downright impressive i'll take another
sin off before i change my mind maybe
you should eat more vegetables and less
people
fewer people marge he should eat fewer
people
funny joke and all but when homer
grabbed marred she was at least on the
second story
and we see him climbing at least two
more stories here and here
so how is marge only perched on the
third story ledge he's not
dead no but his career is
cancel culture
oh homer show just assumes we will go
with the absurdity and not let our mind
wander into the actual mechanics of this
marriage consummation
show is wrong hey hi fellow halloweenies
trying to make us believe that uber
religious ned flanders would celebrate
halloween might be the biggest sin of
this episode
i'm pretty sure snowball 1 was a white
cat so this picture is problematic
it says a lot that in an episode with
dated jokes on racism obesity and even
child abuse that this hat is the most
problematic part
zombies want brains right why are they
walking right past willy i guess it's
maybe because he has no brains
later there will be a joke about how
they're about to eat homer and decide
not to because they can't find brains
but they'll actually have to inspect
homer before they make that decision
dad you killed the zombie flanders he
was a zombie
one of the all-time best simpsons gags
kodos and kang have to make an
appearance in a simpsons halloween
special whether it makes sense or not
cliche
take that washington eat
lead einstein
show's over shakespeare so you're not
only saying that washington einstein
and shakespeare were all buried in
springfield for some reason but they
also
all sauntered over to the school and
then shakespeare hid himself in a locker
i mean you can say this is comedy and
isn't canon all you like but that's some
next level plot apathy right there
the idea was that maybe the library had
another book to reverse the spell but
this is the same book of magic and
spells volume two
bart already had this book also even if
this
was a different book and it isn't why
wouldn't you just look at the original
book to see if there's a reversal spell
trojan ramses magnum chic
the same spell that stops all the
zombies also turns people who have been
turned into snails back to normal you
gotta love those one spell fitzalls
the uh zombies that plagued our town
are now just corpses rotting in our
streets except you literally just showed
them all heading back to the cemetery
and reburying themselves
so which is it diamond joe well i'm sure
glad we didn't turn into mindless
zombies tv hahaha
are you old enough to remember when
television was the dangerous technology
that was going to numb our minds and
make us all stupider
hello talking to you yes you the one
that's got your face buried in your
device watching video after video
playing in a loop to ignore the real
world around you
guys i think they left the room a while
back and it's just auto playing now guys
boring for some reason you all want to
wear the cinemasins pitchfork m on your
body so we slapped that [ __ ] on some
new merch and threw it in the store
posters hoodies tanks socks click on the
merch below the youtube player or click
the store link at cinemasins.com
[Laughter]
nobody calls me chicken needles
nobody
like it's the fruits of the devil
no more rhymes now i mean it hey monkey
you want a peanut
wow george washington take that
washington
one last time